o estresse é uma resposta física e
emocional do corpo a estímulos externos
que são percebidos como ameaças ou
desafios esses estímulos podem incluir
pressões no trabalho problemas de
relacionamento problemas financeiros o
bombardeio de informações negativas que
recebemos todos os dias dos jornais e
redes sociais quando o corpo é exposto a
esses estímulos ele libera hormônios de
estresse como é o caso do cortisol que
aumenta a frequência cardíaca a pressão
arterial e a respiração o objetivo
dessas respostas é parar o seu corpo
para lidar com uma situação desafiadora
pessoal uma certa dose de estresse de
vez em quando é positiva porque é o
mecanismo de sobrevivência criado pela
natureza para lidarmos com situações de
perigo o problema é o stress contínuo e
excessivo onde você não desliga pessoas
que experimentam estresse crônico podem
ter maiores riscos de doença cardíaca de
doenças como diabetes depressão
ansiedade e outros problemas de saúde